everyone I'm Lucy everyone I'm Lucy I'm
Dave what's up HeLa plan is it's your
boy Tom grow up Sam and the same one of
games come here in lovely Cologne
Germany and we are here to celebrate the
Gideons celebrate the games as angular
Merkel was doing today she's in farming
simulator looking like she's just sucked
on a lemon like yeah there's anyone I
can see this a bunch of games here so
we're gonna do like a casual laid-back
chat about what we've been seeing today
what we're playing today
I mean first off we came in super early
to go to Microsoft yeah celebrate the
games at Microsoft's showcase turns out
not many games on Microsoft's your kid
learn to read about grounds running on
PC a game that's available my house yeah
yeah I know what else we do yes I'm yeah
it was programs on a PC yeah so but you
can play backgrounds with yeah yeah so
we all got a rifles and then just camped
out in a bottle bunny yep I got nice
which was disgusting and then we played
some minecraft now surprisingly and
crackdowns you'll be surprised to learn
plays like crackdown this is a good
thing the rock down to didn't play much
like crackdown no that's why it's not a
good crackdown game so the first thing
you see is like agility orbs and I was
like well into it I don't know I didn't
really I wasn't that impressive it it's
the first time I've not made any
crackdowns before
that's probably why like once you start
you have to start from the beginning
which we played an early area but like
you start building up your character and
you get that all when you start jumping
a little bit higher than you're like I
like this and by the time you're done
you're leaping over
buildings and you know jobs something I
did get a really cool like black hole
gun
that sucked ever been into it yeah it
played really loose they've got some new
additions like an air dash and a rocket
jump and that kind of stuff so I felt
fast and loose and felt like crackdown
which is good
none of the cloud stuff lord knows where
that stuff is now where those
calculations I just been somewhere in
you know that's been delayed until next
year now so it would be some time but
shaping up to be very crackdown like
yeah I think up head as well so you we
all play together it's very difficult I
played by myself in like a behind closed
door session later and I'm terrible at
cuphead yes scrub it's just like it's a
lot to take in and obviously it looks
incredible but there's so much on the
screen at any one time and you have to
make very much like the old-school
shooter I played a lot of contra I
played Ikaruga completely Krueger I'm
even I was like what this is insane
I thought I was like I think it was it's
so beautiful and everything is so overly
animated that it's really easy to get
distracted yeah like even a game like
Ikaruga there's a lot going on but
you're basically looking out for colors
and you know like you've got two
different things you can get through you
know the obstacles in a certain way just
by following the colors that you're kind
of keeping my up with this everything is
animating and everything behaves
differently and it randomizes sometimes
the way you like you go into a boss pile
in a spit a couple of enemies when you
come back it won't necessarily be those
same enemies in the same order so you're
like dang I'm just trying to get the
flow into a blog and it will switch off
that keeps it fresh right but also makes
it even more difficult because you're
just getting used to like the patterns
and then you have to suddenly learn to
deal with something completely different
showing off is that like boss battles
now have regular difficulty but there
was have a simple one yeah and even in
my behind closed doors I went on a
simple run but I was by myself
but naps having said that it did feel
quite fun like ice that's the kind of
game that I reckon he sit down with
someone and really like dig into and
play and learn the kind of paths to stop
you can have quite a bit of fun with it
well I did you finish the level that
I've been like practicing for so long
and in the end it was a real like thank
God facepunch moment would you say is
the I'm not having this put money in the
jar but we also sat in on some like
Dolby president it was like we went in
thinking oh yeah cuz they were like I
would work the Xbox one X presentation
yeah it was a Dolby Atmos presentation
is fully like rustled me I was like
alright now I can now in all of our
speakers that I'll never be able to
order it didn't mean that then we went
in and we played well I paid like shadow
war yeah you're playing quantum break
was running behind me I'm not gonna do
wait no was that - yeah or was that am i
this game is already I like it but
that's the point though like everyone's
getting and Cheers
admittedly it all looks very nice but I
had no interest in replaying them rustle
by shadow of war because I called Mike
erigor to help me like more the guy and
then the guy just decided to retreat and
he rode away on Mike Aragon is it Jan so
yeah so that was pretty much Microsoft
well not a lot of new things it's just
kind of like the story of Xbox one X
right now like they don't have much new
but the stuff that they have is good and
the other stuff is old stuff that's in
4k and it looks real nice Dave what you
been into we why you doing Xbox tough I
was Sony I played some apology where war
- yeah call of duty college it was it
boots on the ground they were so many
boots was it back to basics
no there was I was mad well beyond basic
you talking to you was it drop-shot
heaven it was drop-shot heaven so I
played a lot of my play a few hours my
player you had a similar experience
yeah so team deathmatch domination and
war wind it down next time in their path
there wasn't any fun like London you
ain't a online there was no UAVs modern
day but this that the best version of it
was warm we talked about a good a lot
more well if you watch your - Oscars
preview for suppressions you'll find out
which games but basically war is their
new very objective focused mode yeah
more objective focus than quality has
ever been one of the first things I
noticed when I was playing on 0 or 2 is
people still do she things like drop
shot you 360 no-scope
like change change the controls to
tactical and then as soon as they walk
up to you hick lie down as she clear and
slow okay
the game was very fun it was it was flop
into divisions this time and way more
simple for me the fact that they've
taken some that stuff away we were
saying before has actually added a lot
so it feels like now they've gone
through the cycles of the world war to
put a Juiz then my warfare then you know
future gets lost an advanced warfare
Silliman and black ops 3 black ops 3 its
lost the clinical clean aspect of those
futuristic ones it's dirty again
yeah it feels really really internally
Kairi enjoy I've not been an excitable
duty game for the past two I don't mind
admitting that yeah this one I'm
actually pretty sorry for Christmas show
me it's not drop train yeah sorry David
but you also put the new overwatch map
now that that's a good map is really
good it's it's better than like when I
first played I fathers like this is a
cool new map but this one it's it's
changed a way that you look at some of
the character feels very much designed
around the mobility the junk rat has and
the build that I was playing was
actually the bill that where Juncker has
had his up to taper he's got to to my
all rise
so you can do things like you
put mine down jump through a window
throw a mine at the guy you're jumping
to blast away then start like piping out
like I was playing junk ground-attack
and he seemed perfectly situated for it
it was it was so good like the aesthetic
as well like we were interviewing some
of the guys before and it's it's very
far disconnected from very mad max yeah
yeah every every other ever much map has
been you know like the clean city yeah
yeah the nice skylines of Kings Road
there's no real world allegory or like
the real world basis for them to build
off from it sir I know we are if you
like you can tell they had fun making
the map because they were just breaking
stuff apart smash things together
there's a lot of like humor in it just
looking around the map like the whole
car is just over when you spawn you're
in jump rats and Rohan's garage so Road
hogs Harley with the the sidecar the
junk that rides in is in there cuz the
payload blow up when you Adrian I was
actually we want spoilers because
there's gonna be some gameplay up on the
YouTube channel my socks off I was
actually showing a pharaoh as we got the
payload so I didn't actually see because
that's far the story right they put a
ball in the story on the map is themed
but they were kicked out of junk town to
get back into junk town they've like
gathered all this loot so they're gonna
sneak back in like hey tribute this loot
and they're gonna blow up the queen of
junk town who and the queen is like this
legendary collaboratory ol warrior yeah
who am ii won the right to rule junk
town in the colosseum of junk town I
hope they do more that character but for
now like that's some hot gameplay yeah
good map probably already my top five
one myself like some more hot game
they're coming from Capcom games I
played mobile vs. Capcom Infinite today
I recorded some footage it was mostly me
versus Combofiend Co morphine being a
well-known professional mobile player
and now
I got I got curb stomp and it was
incredible it was beautiful but yeah I
don't want to talk too much about that
because there's gonna be an
impressionist video I've got to
youtube.com forward slash GameSpot and
you can watch that there what I do want
to talk about is the new Monster Hunter
yes which is excellent from where I
played yeah it's been so long since I
played a monster on a proper like high
resolution Monster Hunter console we had
there you know we and we you on but you
know high resolution but yeah so they've
gone completely kind of rebuild that
game it's been in development for about
three years which surprised me it's not
like it's been is they've created a lot
of it and they've what they've done is
create a monster that anyone can jump
into now so if you've seen the hype
around one this is the one so not only
have they kind of redesigned it so it's
less like jarring there's a lot of like
legacy to that game that serious now
like if you haven't been planning it for
years some of the stuff is gonna make no
sense for you why it's that way and why
it plays that way they've got rid of a
lot of that and they've kind of made it
an open-world hunting game so it's like
it's perfectly timed because we have
these PC you know survival games where
it's just like the gameplay loop is
going out collecting resources coming
back and then you know just fighting and
doing and stuff it's that but it looks
beautiful
they've kind of got rid of like the
rough edges and from what I've seen so
far like it's very much a monster hunt
again people were worried that it won't
be it'll be unlike monster hunter
because they saw stuff like the damage
numbers coming out and they were like oh
no this is not Montana you could turn
that damage off I found it quite helpful
because it showed me that when I was
doing damage high and low because you
can target different parts of a monster
monster and also your weapons if you're
switching them out it's good to have
that feedback immediately but also the
world is beautiful and I'm just really
looking forward to sitting down in front
of a massive screen on a console and
playing a monster hunter game it's
drop-in dropout co-op you don't have to
go to a guild anymore you can just jump
in at any time and it's gonna be good
man I really really to meet massive use
of music so huge huge I attacked a fish
that was just one weighing it yeah
yeah so that's that's Monster Hunter
that's my favorite game that I played
this it's today games like after I don't
mean to Xbox in the morning I went back
this afternoon
so I played mock-up heads hard as nails
but I did enjoy it and then we played
some fourth zone which looks it looks so
good we've we got a really good it's
custom match we've got a really good lap
of its a game very inclusive yeah I
think it might have been my been never
going to buy it wasn't oh we got some
good finish we're gonna be putting out
later today but I also played Super
Lucky's tale is always Congress back to
it which is I mean like it's a cutesy
platformer it's so I care that says meow
there is a cat and so his speech but his
feet this FIFA who says you know like I
am learning come through or whatever the
voice actors just going yeah me I'm out
it's it's very droll see that sounds
bring when you lose in life when you use
the life lucky goes like squinty eyes
he's like yeah which was quite nice I
like that yeah I enjoyed watching that
and I spectrum of games then yeah games
back from of smells as well cuz we're
our games come you celebrate the games
by smelling bad it's a very big very
busy show then Germany is very warm on
this I mean basically in a green and I'm
regretting my skinny jeans I wore all
black today yeah yeah that was that was
a bad move my friend I only aware I only
own black clothes that's why I should
have worn a t-shirt bad news but join us
again tomorrow we'll be wrapping up day
2 of games con we've got some exciting
stuff on the horizon we've got we're
gonna go see you evil within yeah shadow
of war FIFA FIFA so make sure to join us
then
see you tomorrow bye